fora tv' idea immersion
[Music]
evening miss Stuart brand as usual
incest is bad in biology but probably
good and intellectual Affairs and I
didn't really realize this that Alex
right he was speaking tonight has
already been a part of the long now
operation Jim Mason found him a couple
years ago and we were just starting the
Rosetta project to get all the languages
in the world online and Alex came out
and was the information architect for
the original Rosetta site wire-framed it
up and got it in the direction it is now
advancing rapidly I was just asking him
beforehand now that you're the
information architect for the New York
Times what exactly does that mean and I
realized it was going to be a long
answer so if you want to if he doesn't
explain during the talk ask him about it
afterwards the thing that I guess is
common with most of the talks in this
series is we look at phenomena that are
usually looked at in terms of their
scope and breadth impact but not so
often in terms of their time depth and
the time depth gives you this other
perspective on all sorts of things and
something that is obsessing us more and
more from week to week and day to day
cell phones and whatnot is managing
information they say this is the
biological century it's also still an
accelerating information century and so
the long-term perspective on dealing
with that is well we got tonight from
Alex right
Oh Thank You Stuart and Thank You Xander
and Danielle for for setting this up
tonight thanks to all you for for coming
out so it's a real I'm really thrilled
to be here I've been a longtime fan of
the long now foundation and to Stuart
mentioned I've done some work with them
in the past and I'm a member and I hope
you all are too and you know especially
as a first time and being a relatively
unknown author it's a great opportunity
I'm really pleased have a chance to talk
about some of the ideas of my book and
so you know my book just came out a few
weeks ago and I've been doing a little
bit of publicity around it and a couple
of interviews and a few weeks ago I
didn't it a quick little email interview
with some folks at Powell's Books up in
Portland Oregon I don't know if people
have heard of them great little great
big independent bookstore up there right
yeah definitely buy your books online
from them
it's anyway so this little QA and they
asked one of the questions they asked
was what was your favorite book as a
child and I had to think about that for
a little while and I didn't really have
a single favorite book but you know the
ones that came to my different times you
know the ones that might have come to
mind would be like maybe the Phantom
Tollbooth or a wrinkle in time or you
know I wasn't gonna say Lord of the
Rings all that was probably true but um
but uh the book that I ended up
mentioning this is gonna sound like I'm
playing to the crowd here but this is
honest-to-god what I said was the Whole
Earth Catalog and the reason I mentioned
this was uh when I was about 10 years
old my parents had these friends in
Cambridge Mass kind of these hippie
friends and if they were well actually
he was a physics professor but they were
philosophical hippies thing and they
started sending me the Pole Earth
Catalog every time every year that came
out I don't think it was every year but
whenever it came out they would send me
a copy of it and I didn't really know
what to make of it at first I would just
sort of flip through it and think it was
kind of a bunch of you know interesting
strange stuff in here like stories about
you know how to build your own yurt or
how'd it go kayaking or you know okay it
was just a real mishmash of stuff I
think they had a page about the Kama
Sutra what day it was particularly
fascinating but uh but it also had as I
recall this whole section on whole
systems and this whole idea that and
what was interesting to me about the
book and over
I started to sort of understand it a
little bit was it took this sort of
broad view and this sort of this this
had this sort of approach to really
tying together a lot of seemingly sort
of disconnected information and
presenting it in in a very in a new sort
of context and it was very different
from most books and you couldn't really
read it from front to back but it was
really just a lot of sort of chunk you
know little chunks of information that
were sort of pulled together in
interesting ways and a lot of people
have I think since you know made the
argument that in a way it sort of
anticipated the web which i think is
true I can't say it's a 12 year old I
had a great vision of that I think I was
more in the Kama Sutra but but but it
did I think have a sort of point of view
to it which was this notion that that
that things were connected and that you
know that we could look at sort of the
artifacts of human culture in in a
larger context in kind of an ecological
context and looking at an understanding
that you know that we could actually
look at what we do you know the kind of
systems we create as part of maybe you
know larger systems or looking at you
know how systems work in nature and so I
think that's it's a very interesting
sort of point of view there that I think
has has had legs and I think especially
as the web has taken shape a lot of
people have started to think about it in
those terms as you know possibly a kind
of you know as being sort of an
ecosystem or as being maybe even having
some possibly some kind of evolutionary
significance and that's okay I'm going
to talk about a little bit but this sort
of gets me into the what I want to talk
about tonight which is this notion of
deep history and the term deep history
gets it doesn't it's not a real clearly
defined term a different people use it
in different ways but the way I'm using
it tonight is is it's really a way of
looking at human culture in on sort of
an evolutionary timeline so as opposed
to the sort of traditional you know
narrative of certainly Western culture
which usually starts about you know what
two three thousand years ago with the
Greeks usually the idea is to maybe take
a sort of a longer view and to try to
explore whether there are patterns that
we can recognize in some of our in
working even in recent human history
that might be part of a longer-term
trajectory that we could
explore in terms of you know of
evolution another way of putting it
might be so so the question I want to
ask tonight is really you know can we
say that information systems evolve and
if so what does that tell us about it
you know that the sort of experience
that we're all going through today I
think we all you know can look around
and see that we're living in kind of a
you know pretty interesting time and
that there's I was a huge volume of
information being produced right now in
all kinds of new ways and we're seeing
all kinds of social change and cultural
change and you know political change and
you know we're going through a period of
a lot of disruption and as I say there
there have been people who've suggested
that this is some sort of evolutionary
leap forward well I think we have to be
a little bit careful about that but I
want to give you a couple of examples of
people who sort of tried to make this
case one is Ray Kurzweil who I still
give a talk at the one that foundation I
think a year or two ago and he makes the
case that you know the emergence of
networked computers is this basically an
evolutionary event that we're
effectively seeing the emergence of a
new kind of global intelligence that you
know that is on par with the creation of
a new species or something so it's a
pretty you know and he's a brilliant guy
he's he's out there but but this is
certainly a point of view that has some
you know credibility this was also a
similar lines I Danny Hillis another
long now person this is from an article
in Wired a few years ago makes this made
a similar sort of case that you know we
are living through a period where we
could look at this as sort of an you
know an evolutionary leap forward well I
think we have to be a little careful
with words like evolution and before we
start sort of completely buying to this
notion that you know that information
systems literally evolve I think we have
to really recognize that there are some
pretty strong and fairly you know
legitimate objections to using the word
evolution in that context I think the
late Stephen Jay Gould probably voiced
this as well as anybody where he
suggested that really using the term
as a descriptor for the way human
cultural systems move forward is a
little bit misleading and he made the
case they and one sort of common fallacy
is this notion that evolute that
evolution equals progress and his point
of view was that you know if you really
look in the history and at the sort of
evolutionary history of the planet the
most successful species on earth are and
have always been bacteria right they've
been around for two billion years they
haven't really changed much and yet they
are the dominant you know by any
objective measure the dominant life-form
on earth right and so they're an
evolutionary success story that really
hasn't had to do much right so when we
sort of start to sort of give ourselves
you know too much credit you know as you
know in evolutionary terms I think it's
worth keeping in mind that our own
experience is pretty limited and that
you know we should really define our
terms carefully before we start you know
talking about evolution this is a phrase
that's often used by a so called
cultural relativist who objectid of
talking about human culture in sort of
biological terms it means all culture
comes from culture so the argument is
that all the culture is human culture is
such a complex phenomenon that it can't
be reduced to sort of simple biological
evolution not that evolution simple but
that it's a complex phenomenon that
cultural phenomena come out of culture
and that it's not predictable and I
can't you know we have to be careful
about trying to you know boil it down to
a simplistic argument so I think it's
worth acknowledging those objections
before I get into this because I'm going
to talk a bit about the ways in which I
think evolutionary theory actually does
apply to the progression of information
systems but I want to at least
acknowledge the objections and talk
about you know how far maybe we can take
that case so just to go all the way back
so that the very early if we look at the
very earliest you know emergence of life
on Earth at least complex life complex
organic life for a long time that the
the conventional wisdom and among
biologists was that
you know life forms evolved as sort of
individual units and that you had you
know simple life forms that
progressively you know through
adaptation became more complex and more
specialized and eventually resulted in
you know very complex organisms like
ourselves well a couple of decades ago a
biologist named Lynn Margulis
sort of challenged that conventional
wisdom and she suggested that actually
we could look at the origin of life in a
different way and her theory was that
the very earliest complex life forms
actually emerged as kind of social
collectives and so her theory is that
actually the earliest sort of
multicellular life took shape as unit as
individual single-celled organisms
started to collaborate and work together
and effectively sort of exchange data
with each other and that over time those
sort of social collectives coalesced
into larger organisms that eventually
started to cohere and then to make a
very long and I'm rattling
oversimplifying here but but over time
those complex those larger life forms
then also started to aggregate into sort
of social organizations and so the
reason this is interesting I think is it
raises the question of what's the
boundary between sort of an individual
life for individual unit of life and
sort of a social organization and can it
be said that a social organization
evolves and so if you take this point of
view it would suggest that yes there is
a sense in which social units actually
do kind of evolve in the same way that
individual life forms evolve so how does
that work well there are a couple of
sort of patterns at work there one is
networks so at you know at the simplest
level at all sorts of sort of levels of
the biological hierarchy there are
there's this pattern of networks of sort
of entities that coalesce into kind of
self-organizing groups that that are the
sort of flat there's not really a top
but they tend to sort of you know come
together or drift apart in a sort of you
know self-organizing way
the other pattern at work is hierarchies
and what you see in the you know in the
history of complex life forms is that as
networks take shape they tend to give
rise to hierarchies that emerge out of
those networks and so in the case of
organic life you had you know networks
of individual organisms came together
and over time new sort of hierarchies
like complex life-forms emerged then as
those or as those complex organisms
started to come together they also form
sort of social networks over time new
kinds of sort of social hierarchies
emerged out of that so this is a sort of
pattern of networks giving rise to
hierarchies which in turn coalesce into
networks which in turn give rise to new
hierarchies so this is sort of a theme
that I try to work with in the book is
that how far does that pattern really go
and what can that tell us about the way
that the that people and other animals
actually interact with each other and is
there something we can learn from that
in terms of thinking about information
systems so we can look at and you know
throughout the animal kingdom there are
all kinds of examples of these sorts of
dynamics at work and I'm not going to go
too deep into this but but in the book I
do spend some time looking at the for
instance that the the study of insect
colonies which is a great example of how
the sort of social organisms take shape
where you have units of sort of fairly
simple individual life-forms who come
together and sort of more you know a
higher kind of intelligence and merges
out of their interaction so if you
there's all kinds of stories about ant
colonies and beehives and how they they
function in a sense as kind of
information processing machines that
that have certain characteristics that
seem to not be predicted by the
individual intelligence of the of the
organism and if we go further sort of up
the chain into more complex life forms
that's not working
we can also see these sort of sorts of
patterns and other animals as well so
this is this notion of kind of a super
organism that is an entity that's made
up of individual life-forms that where
the the social group takes on its own
sort of characteristics and and
functions as a almost as a kind of
higher brain function for the group but
with the kind of distributed
intelligence and these kinds of
phenomena have often been used as kind
of a metaphor for the web where we see
also this very distributed kind of
intelligence where we have you know a
network that's very flat and yet we seem
to see you know certain kinds of
clusters or organs or sort of ad-hoc
organizations emerge out of an otherwise
flat network and so there's a lot of
computer scientists have actually looked
at these sorts of biological models of
computing as as frameworks for thinking
about the way the way computers work and
Kevin Kelly's written about this one
very eloquently and out of control and
quite a few other folks have sort of
explored this this sort of theme so I
think there is a case to be made that
there are information systems at work in
the natural world and that there are
these sorts of patterns seem to exist
and if that's true you know if we can
say that other animals do sort of
traffic and information and that they
have something like and if we call it a
system or at least a strategy for for
exchanging information with each other
then we can start to ask the question
you know how does that what is the
mechanism by which that sort of
phenomena happens because we can't
necessarily explain that purely in terms
of genetic evolution in other words you
know if we just sort of look at the DNA
level there's only so much that's really
going to tell us about these sort of
social interactions so there is a pretty
compelling theory out there that sort of
explains how this works
professor Yeo Wilson famous biologist at
Harvard he's the guy who coined the term
social biology I'm sure a lot of people
I know he is he is this theory of
epigenetic rules and an epigenetic rules
he defines it is a
it's basically a it's it's a concept
there's not an actual you know
biological thing you can point to but
the idea is that it's it's a framework
for explaining how certain kinds of
processes sort of cognitive processes or
mental capacities get get invoked get
evolved that actually enable a social
organization to create a culture in
other words it explains how individual
organisms over time develop certain
characteristics through genetic
inheritance that enable cultural
behaviors to be transmitted from
generation to generation and his
argument is that through epigenetic
rules certain cultural patterns emerge
that are actually passed on through
culture from generation to generation
and and those patterns are reinforced in
the genetic code so this is kind of a
little bit of a complex idea but I hope
it's making at least a little bit of
sense so he gives a few examples of
epigenetic rules so he distinguishes
between primary and secondary rules so
the primary a primary epigenetic rule
would be the fact that we all perceive
sort of the same range of the color
spectrum would be kind of a primary
epigenetic role we all are all equipped
to sort of see things in the same way
similarly a lot of our sort of senses
sort of seem to be governed by this
claim you know there's some value to
humanity as a whole in us all seeing the
same color spectrum or hearing the same
range of sound but he then takes that
argument a little bit further and this
is where it gets a little controversial
he suggests that you can also use this
framework to explain for instance why in
every known human culture that's ever
been studied people are afraid of snakes
right well there's no gene that tells us
to be afraid of snakes
that's nothing no there's no gene you
can point to as far as we know I think
for all the genetic sequencing they're
doing they haven't found the fear of
snakes gene and yet everybody pretty
much you know not it maybe not
everybody's afraid of snakes but all
cultures have some sort of you know
serpent mythology or some reason you
know so there's something about about us
that seems to be predisposed to fearing
snakes
and so the way he would explain that is
that it's sort of a combination of genes
and that basically over a long period of
time the people that were afraid of
snakes were much more likely to pass on
their genes than the people who weren't
afraid of snakes so oh so it's you know
so he takes a little bit further even
and this is where it really does he gets
into you know a very contentious area
you suggest that you can also use this
to explain why there are so many similar
narrative archetypes in human cultures
for instance the the hero's descent the
presence of trickster gods and all kinds
of mythologies he goes so far as to
suggest that there's some evolutionary
basis that these sorts of archetypes
actually have an evolutionary role and
in helping to helping the group to
survive and and reproduce that there's
some value in these sort of you know
it's certain kinds of of cultural
archetypes and actually creating a
stable cultural system that actually
benefits that the larger group and the
last one on this list is really where I
think it gets particularly interesting
he seems he suggests and and there's a
lot of data to back this up that also
our propensity for categorizing
information also has something to do
with an epigenetic rule so let me give
you an example of what that means so if
we think about it
in every known human culture that's ever
been studied people categorize
information about plants and animals and
if you think about it this is sort of
the primordial information system right
if you're living in a tribal community
you know 80 thousand years ago it's
essential to have a shared understanding
of the natural world you have to know
you know what snakes are poisonous
you know what plants you can eat and you
have to have something and that that
kind of information you know get to
built up over time there were a lot of
trial and error right a lot of people
eating the wrong plants or the wrong
mushrooms or whatever and and that
information gets preserved in a sort of
cultural framework that gets passed on
and gets actually embedded in the
language and over time these
classifications actually become more and
more complex and you start to see you
know people start to actually create
categories of you know noticing that you
know there's maybe a category of things
that fly and there's a category of you
know something like mammals and
something like insects and those
categories get more and more granular
over time now these are called folk
taxonomy x' and this is not to be
confused with focus on amis which
something we might have heard of it was
maybe last year's buzzword but folk
taxonomy czar basically systems for
categorizing information about plants
and animals that are present actually in
every human culture that's ever been
studied from Papua New Guinea to the
outback of Australia to you know the
tribes of you know Native America every
culture seems to have a system like this
and what's particularly interesting is
that these systems bear an incredible
degree of resemblance to each other they
have certain characteristics that even
in cultures that evolved that you know
that took shape you know physically on
separate continents over tens of
thousands of years folk taxonomy are
almost identical and this is kind of a
pretty surprising thing if you
consider how different a lot of these
cultures are in other ways but they all
have certain characteristics they almost
invariably have a concept of sort of
higher you know the highest order of
life-forms like plants and animals they
have a concept of sort of a genus and a
species the subspecies and what's
interesting about that is that that that
categorization that's that sort of
hierarchy is invariable in every culture
that's ever been studied there's a guy
named Brent anthropologist named Brent
Berlin who spent his whole life studying
this and every tribal society ever
documented has a taxonomy of the natural
world that's about that's invariably
five levels deep as five levels of
categorization and the actual contents
of it may vary slightly but but
generally they're actually pretty
similar so it would seem to suggest that
this might be an example of an
epigenetic rule well nobody's really
studied that anthropologist and by you
know social biologists haven't quite
gotten come to terms on this yet so but
it seems to suggest there might be an
epigenetic role so I actually when I was
writing the book I wrote a note to
Professor Wilson and I said you know
what do you think and he said I agree I
think he said he thinks this is actually
an example of an epigenetic rule at work
for what it's worth this again it I
can't really cite anything you know in
the scientific literature to back that
up but it does seem like a pretty
compelling evidence that that might be
you know an example that we might have a
very deep biological disposition to
categorize in the world in in
hierarchical terms well a folk taxonomy
does not look like this right this is an
example of a focus on amis I mentioned
earlier and this is the kind of thing I
think you see a lot on the web these
days I'm fast-forwarding a little bit we
I think a lot of people when they you
know when we look at the phenomena of
network information there's sort of this
idea that hierarchies are going to kind
of fault the old sort of hierarchies of
knowledge are kind of falling apart and
everything is very sort of networked and
sort of loosey-goosey now but it would
seem that you know that our did we do
have this disposition towards
categorizing the world in hierarch in a
hierarchical way that that's pretty
deep-seated
this is probably going to a little more
detail and we want to get into but this
is a berlin has developed kind of a
model for how this for what these folk
taxonomy is typically look like an
interesting shouldn't is what you know
why why are they so similar and where
does that structure come from this sort
of five or six level taxonomy you know
come from what is the sort of
explanation for that well there was an
anthropologist named Emile Durkheim
who's wrote a lot around the turn of the
century and he also studied folk
taxonomy and he thought he believed and
a lot of people agree that there's a
relationship between folk taxonomy Xand
family trees this takes a little
explaining but he believed that in in
cultures that don't have any sort of
ability to record information and they
don't you know cultures that don't have
any alphabetic you know writing
technology that they use these folk
taxonomy as a way of projecting their
understanding of family relationships
and so it's it's very common in folk
taxonomy for people to describe a
particular animal is belonging to kind
of a parent category or to have kind of
family relationships we do this all the
time we talk about our our cousins the
chimpanzees for instance you know the
way that people use those sort of family
terms that there's something about the
way we relate to our own genealogy that
is somehow bound up with our
understanding of the natural world
here's another example of a family tree
this Charles Darwin's family tree
and here's another family tree so this
is a genealogy of the Greek gods now
what's interesting here is that there is
actually a relationship between this
kind of mythology and an taxonomy and
this may take a little explaining but if
you look at most mythology's and world
cultures every that there are ways of
explaining the natural world in addition
to being collections of stories that
people tell they also have kind of coded
so every God kind of has a double you
know they often have sort of animal
animals that they're associated with or
natural elements you know Zeus is the
god of thunder or you know what have you
or this one you know this goddess turns
into a deer or whatever and throughout
doing cultures there are these kinds of
connections between taxonomy Zand
mythologies and that relationship
actually goes pretty deep so this was a
a great book by who partnership and it's
called information ages and they talk
about this a little bit and they talk
about how genealogy is actually an ideal
way for people to classify the world
especially we're talking about
preliterate societies here it gives
people a framework for sort of capturing
what they know about the world around
them and encoding it in these sort of
you know mythological related you know
stories and and then that can be
preserved through generations by having
the sort of genealogical structure
around it and so what you see in a lot
of these cultures is that the mythology
is as I say it's it's really kind of an
information system it's a way of
categorizing information and containing
a lot of information that's kind of
cross-referenced in in interesting ways
and and those systems that kind of
taxonomy often plays a pretty direct
role in actually shaping the way that
people live together and the actual
social structure that's sort of you know
that grows up around it so this is a
photo of a Zuni Pueblo so the Zuni
people live in what stood today or live
in what's today mostly New Mexico and it
was interesting when the Spanish
conquistadors first encountered the Zuni
they noticed something very unusual
about the way they they they set up
their villages their pueblos each Pueblo
was divided into quadrants and each
quadrant had a particular sort of family
kind of kind of a clan within the larger
tribe and at each Pueblo there was the
exact same structure so there was like
you know they would have in
north-south-east-west and then there'd
be a group that lived in the middle and
each of those groups had a particular
name and a particular
a sort of relation set of relationships
with the natural world so you would have
for instance the people in the north
would have a particular association with
like bears and you know a certain kind
of snake and a certain kind of bird and
certain elements of the weather they
might be associated with rain you know
or wind or fire or what-have-you and you
would also have a particular sort of
social responsibilities divided up
between these groups so the people in
the middle would be kind of the priests
class and the people on the you know and
one side of town would basically be
responsible for for keeping the peace
and the people on you know in another
quadrant would be responsible for making
war and we're presumably sort of sit
around and watch Fox News so you had
yeah you had kind of a a division of
social responsibility that was very much
tied up in this you know in this kind of
taxonomy this sort of understanding of
the natural world another example in the
outback of Australia they discovered
very very similar sort of setup where a
lot of the tribes in the in the outback
would have the Aboriginal people would
have a similar sort of division of clans
within the larger tribal group and they
would have certain sort of dietary
restrictions like this group you know
this particular clan would only eat
kangaroo and this one would only eat
emus and and they would also be sort of
charged with having a particular sort of
domain of expertise about you know
particular animals and particular
natural elements so again it's the the
idea is that the you know in these sort
of preliterate societies there's a
fairly deep relationship between
taxonomy and social organization and so
and and this is something you know even
this is something that a pattern that
over time has has continued to play out
as we've seen that the relationship
between information systems and social
organization goes pretty far back and
and there's always been a fairly direct
relationship between the way people
organize information and the way they
actually organize themselves
so and today you know we still organize
things into hierarchies right this is a
sitemap from from a website and seems to
have you know a lot if you see these
things a lot of them seem to echo this
kind of structure where you have this
kind of hierarchical organization that
kind of somehow looks a little bit like
a family tree and people often do
websites often talk about pages on a
website having like a parent-child
relationship to each other which is you
know kind of an echo of a like a folk
taxonomy or
you know that kind of thinking so it
seems to be based on some sort of there
seems to be some deep you know
propensity that we have for organizing
information in a certain way so so just
to bring things forward a little bit so
so fokin economies we're really kind of
a as I said a kind of basic way of
organizing information for most of our
species history and I think they're very
actually not studied all that often and
I think they probably should because
we're you know for at least probably
eighty to ninety thousand years they
were kind of a dominant way that people
organized information was in these sort
of mythological taxonomic systems that
were basically transmitted orally you
know through culture
what happened about just a fast-forward
now to about thirty thousand years ago
so for for most of our species history
people didn't really have symbolic
artifacts they didn't really communicate
using external symbols or objects
what happened about thirty thousand
years ago and this is kind of a hallmark
of evolution is that adaptations tend to
happen when there's a change in the
environment or change changing
conditions
what happened about thirty thousand
years ago was the last great European
Ice Age and what happened about that
time was suddenly across much of the you
know parts of the much of the world that
was populated by humans suddenly
temperatures started to plunge and the
small game that people had been used to
relying on I mean for most of our
species history people have been sort of
small game hunters eating sort of
squirrels and rabbits and pigeons and
and living in very sort of loosen it
sort of scavenger groups
what happened about 30,000 years ago as
the ice age game was that that small
game started to dry up and a lot of the
vegetation started to disappear and
people suddenly it was colder out they
had to start basically banding together
to survive they were you know starting
to live in caves for instance and the
the food supply increasingly again they
weren't able to find the the the ready
food supply that they had been able to
to to find they started to hunt big game
like woolly mammoths and big you know
8-foot tall
prehistoric cows and they sorted
realized that they actually needed to
collaborate to do that you know is sort
of anybody can kill a pigeon but if
you're gonna bring down a woolly mammoth
you actually have to have sort of a team
and and you had a larger organization a
larger sort of group of people living
together and it's sort of increasingly
growing settlements so what happened as
people were starting to live in these
larger settlements it was about this
time that they actually started to
create things like beads in huge numbers
this is also about the time they started
making cave paintings and it seems that
this this activity was actually a
response to changing environmental
conditions where people suddenly had to
sort of relate to each other in ways
that they hadn't had to before so when
people were in sort of loose-knit
organizations for loose-knit groups you
sort of knew who everybody was you know
you might you know you knew who your
sister was and you knew you know
so-and-so had this sort of status and in
the you know in the group but you're
suddenly in a larger organization a
larger group of maybe hundreds of people
living together it's not so easy to keep
track of who's who so there's a pretty
compelling theory that a lot of this
early symbolism was a response to that -
that need to be able to communicate
status or to be able to negotiate
relationships with people that you
didn't necessarily know and so it's
incredible if you look at the
archaeological data around this period
there were settlements where people
apparently spent the bulk of their lives
creating these creating beads and
ornaments and maybe they just had a lot
of time on their hands because I think I
was cold outside and they were at
something you know they were spending a
lot of time inside but but it was
incredibly important
people for some reason that they be able
to create these these sort of totemic
objects and what this did was it
facilitated what we called a release
from social proximity so they said what
as people were able to basically use
object use symbolic objects to
communicate their status to each other
they were able to to get beyond then you
know that the need to have direct
personal knowledge of who everybody was
they could actually have sort of you
know mediated relationships with people
you could sort of tell you know what
status somebody had and who you know who
was who who was married that sort of
thing and what's interesting about this
is it it created a an opportunity as
people were able to negotiate those
relationships and people came together
in these sort of networks as you know
large numbers of people start living
together new kinds of social hierarchies
emerged out of that so it was around
this time that we saw the first what we
would recognize as kind of tribal chief
dumps so you started to see a real sort
of social hierarchy take shape around
around and it really as a as a result of
or at least partly as a result of this
information technology that it allowed
people to you know to facilitate these
kinds of relationships so it's
interesting to look at that relationship
between sort of annuity and kind of in a
way disruptive information technology
and and a wave of social change that
seemed to happen and in response to it
and I think it's interesting also to
think about this notion of a release
from proximity and what that you know
and how we actually do the same thing
today there's a few examples of how we
do that today right so I think like eBay
seller ratings are a great example of
this how you're actually able to
negotiate a relationship with somebody
you've never met using a kind of
symbolic totem that tells you something
about this person you'll never meet and
yet you sort of rely on that right so I
think it's a sort of it may be something
you know some parallel there so so to
fast forward another few thousand years
so this notion that you know that of
information technology emerging as a
response to changing environmental
conditions is a theme that seems to
recur at different periods in history
this app seemed to happen again about
5,000 years ago when the first alphabets
emerged so it was about 5,000 years ago
that people started to live together in
larger agricultural settlements so as
the technology of agriculture took shape
you saw larger and larger sort of stable
settlements starting to emerge and
people are living together and yet
larger organizations and as a result of
that a lot of Commerce started to happen
people were trading back up sorry there
we go
people were trading with each other and
as they started to trade more and there
were more and more people and there was
a more more of a sort of volume of
activity going on they needed to keep
track of that and so the very earliest
forms of writing were actually form of
counting they actually emerged as sort
of counting tokens
I think Samuel Johnson once said that no
man but a fool ever wrote except for
money well he was he was actually quite
right there the ratchet would not be
writing if it wasn't for money and and
this was one of the first examples of
that over time those counting objects
got a little more sophisticated and as
there was a growing volume of
transactions people needed to do more
than just count they actually needed to
start making lists of things and so the
first sort of alphabetic writing really
emerged as sort of lists of you know
inventory or lists of goods and that in
turn you know sort of yielded even more
cut you know sort of complex sorts of
accounting and record-keeping the first
sort of government bureaucracies emerged
to sort of keep track and I've been
condensing a very very long story here
but over time the you know the the
modern sort of institution as we would
recognize that the modern sort of
bureaucratic institution took shape
around the technology of writing and
eventually you know that writing became
more like what we would recognize as
writing today I started to become more
narrow
people started to tell us you know to
keep track of Chronicles or stories
about the king or and then stories about
the kingdom and that eventually you know
somebody wrote Gilgamesh and then
eventually you know it became kind of
literature but during this period there
was a the emergence of a sort of class
of literate people as this technology
took shape a kind of social division
took shape
took hold where you started to see a a
small group of people who had who had
acquired the capacity for reading and
writing and they became kind of a
privilege to cast the cast of scribes
which the scribe was considered in
Babylon and Sumeria to have a status
kind of second only to the king and and
a sort of literate culture started to
emerge and for you know most of human
history that ensued there was always
kind of a fairly small sort of upper
cast of people who actually knew how to
read and the vast majority of people
still continued to live in an oral
culture and and this relationship
between kind of literate culture and
oral culture is also a theme that I that
that I explore in the book quite a bit
because I think it's it's very relevant
to so some of the sort of conflicts that
we're seeing today some of the cultural
transitions that we're seeing today this
is a guy named Walter J Young who is a
8th he's passed away he was a linguist
and he has written a lot about oral
culture and how we you know how to
understand them and I think it's
something that oral cultures are
actually not very well understood and
not widely studied for some reason I
think because we have a kind of a
cultural bias towards literacy because
we live in a literate culture and he
makes the point that to really
understand it context for this is he
believes that electronic media
especially communications through
computers and television and you know
the growing wave of electronic media he
thought represented actually the
resurgence of oral culture and that to
really understand what's going on we
have to actually understand it through
the filter of our culture and not just
through our sort of traditional literate
you know literary culture and so what he
suggests is the
there were certain characteristics of
oral culture that it's as he says here
additive an aggregate of and
participatory meaning that it grows up
over time through large numbers of
people sort of you know pooling their
experiences that over time a sort of you
know folk wisdom emerges or people you
know over time that oral cultures create
create and understanding that's that's
an aggregate understanding
whereas literate culture tends to be
much more predicated on kind of the
individual really you know trying to
take sort of an objective stance and
really sort of digging into something
and being analytic and and sort of
abstracting from the situation and that
they're very different modes of thought
and that their won't so thought that
that kind of can coexist but they they
often sort of come into conflict with
each other and so it's interesting to
think about oral culture in the context
of of what we what we're seeing today I
think on the especially on that on the
web in a way I think you could say we're
seeing actually a very oral culture
taking shape if you look at the way that
people use things like email you know
instant messaging twittering blogging
that's a very conversational kind of
tone to it
and this is an example of a review and
Amazon for example where you know a lot
of people are able to you know go in and
basically post their own comments or
their own reviews and yet this sort of
you know this sort of experience coexist
with a much more literate experience
where you often have kind of the
editorial review of a book like the
Library Journal review or something and
then you'll have a long list or
sometimes a long list of reader reviews
and the reader reviews again they sort
of build up over time and they you know
you see get sort of an average rating so
they get kind of aggregated whereas the
the editorial review kind of stands
alone is considered a little more
authoritative so I think it's an
interesting example of have those sort
of oral and literate cultures continued
to co-exist but don't quite come
together you know so so just to back
back up to where we were
so as these literate culture started to
emerge you started to see the you see
that you started to see the first sort
of institutional bureaus emerged to
support the the preservation and the you
know and the dissemination of
information information so you saw the
first libraries emerge and the first
libraries were typically kind of temple
libraries or government archives and
then over time they got bigger and
bigger and they were the for instance
the famous library at Alexandria you saw
these sort of institutional hierarchies
emerging to take to sort of take custody
of this growing body of recorded
knowledge and and there were you know
there were ups and downs I mean you saw
you know they saw the great Classical
period and then that sort of collapsed
and there was a period of sort of
instability and then eventually the you
know the new you know sort of new kinds
of libraries and archival institutions
emerged in the Middle Ages in Europe
some of them again making very very long
story short here but it's interesting to
look at as that sort of back and forth
happened you saw chained evolutions in
the technology of writing so in the
early in the early Classical period you
went from sort of having a writing
inscribed in stone tablets and on
papyrus scrolls to eventually you saw
the emergence of what we would think of
as a book and that really took shape
mostly in Europe in the you know the
sort of what's called a codex book which
means a book with kind of pages that you
can flip through took shape in Europe
sort of during the Dark Ages and into
the medieval era and during that period
you actually saw some interesting
innovations in the actual content of the
you know of the of the books themselves
so if you think about a scroll it's a
very linear kind of way of reading I
mean it has it sort of the scroll is
typically kind of one page and you read
it from the top to the bottom you think
about a book it's more of kind of a
random-access thing where you can you
know go into any page and read it and
jump around and
you know they're it's it's sort of a
it's a it's an innovation it's it's an
it's a new way of organizing information
and during the medieval period there
were some really interesting innovations
that took shape this is a example of a
Canon table and this was done in one of
the I think one of the Irish monasteries
I think and this is a kind of a
hypertext like view of of the Bible and
so what this does is it basically is
kind of a visual index to books of the
Bible so it basically takes like a story
in the Bible and it cross references
across all the different Gospels and the
idea here is that you know the person
who created this was able to kind of
zoom out from the Bible and create this
kind of view into it that had this that
had this kind of height you know this
sort of conceptual hierarchy
that let you kind of you know extracting
a zoom in and zoom out of the of the
text or some other interesting this is
an example of a medieval bestiary and I
wanted to bring this up this is also a
really interesting example of where oral
and literate cultures come together the
bestiary was an extremely popular book
in medieval Europe and it was a book
basically it's a book about animals and
their kind they're often kind of picture
books there it was based on an old Greek
text but it was sort of added to over
time over about a thousand years it was
the the story is kind of evolved and
each of the stories about the animals
was eventually sort of layered on with
some sort of allegorical significance so
for instance you know there was a story
about the elephant who had no knees and
the elephant had no knees because it was
kind of like a pillar of faith or
something like that and there's a story
about the lion and the lion was
considered to be a representative of
Jesus and so for instance if people have
read like the lion in which of the
Wardrobe that's where that image comes
from with the lion as as Jesus cuz dates
all the way back to to this book so I
think what's interesting about this I
think you can see some echoes of some
interesting things here so you'll notice
that in this at least in this image
Adam is kind of classifying the animals
so he's kind of putting them in
categories and and that whole notion of
atom naming the animals is sort of
somehow kind of an echo of that that
basic human instinct to to categorize
the natural world well it's also
interesting is that this the bestiary
was incredibly popular among medieval
people who couldn't read and often often
a parish church in in Europe would only
have two books they would have a copy of
the Bible and they would have a bestiary
and people the villagers or you know
peasants would love to come and hear
stories told to them out of the bestiary
because it was a very you know they were
very visual and they sort of somehow
resonated with this sort of deep
interest that people had in animals and
an understanding the natural world it
was a way to sort of connect that that
sort of folk tradition with this you
know with this you know religious
meaning and somehow is a way of bringing
together that sort of oral you know sort
of an oral culture with a kind of
literate culture and even if you go into
churches around this time they often
have images that are right out of the
bestiary all over the walls like they'll
have images of you know of lions and
different animals that are directly tied
to the to the images that are in the
bestiary so so also during this period
around the sort of late Middle Ages and
beginning of the Renaissance in the
medieval monasteries they were you know
we sort of tend to think of them as
being a lot of the monasteries as being
sort of centers of book production and
our scholarship which they were but
there was also an interesting technique
that was being developed in the
monasteries about this time it was
called the art of memory and the art of
memory was a particular technique that
was taught in certain monasteries that
enabled monks to memorize incredible
amounts of information by some accounts
people who mastered this technique could
actually memorize something like two up
to two hundred thousand pages of
information there were people who
claimed to have memorized the whole
Bible you know every point of like the
Canon Law all kinds of legal documents I
mean they apparently perform these
incredible feats of memorization
and the way they did that was by doing
these complex visualizations and the
it's a lot of the technique has been
lost but from what we understand the way
they did it was they would create these
kind of memory palaces that they would
visualize and they would use and within
each palace there'd be a series of rooms
and within each room there would be a
set of objects that would have a
particular meaning that they would
memorize and then somehow those objects
would then be strung together into you
know into words and text that could be
memorized you know very involved
technique took years and years and
decades to master but what's interesting
about it is that it's somehow invoked a
kind of spatial memory in a way that we
think of memorizing it's just sort of
memorizing sort of maybe rows and rows
of text but it was a very different way
a kind of three-dimensional way of
invoking memory and people some scholars
have suggested that maybe there's kind
of a an echo of kind of a hypertext kind
of idea here where if you think about
the way people sort of navigate
interactive information spaces that it's
also kind of a 3d kind of experience and
uses that kind of spatial memory and
there was even a guy named a guy who
actually tried to build kind of a
physical facsimile of the art of memory
a guy named Camilo who built a thing
called the theatre of memory and it was
this incredibly popular attraction in
Venice in the 16th century I think where
he basically built this this big
contraption and it was kind of like it
was kind of like a big mechanical web
browser
the idea was anybody could walk into
this thing it apparently was kind of a
big theater and you would walk in and
there would be all these little windows
like wooden boxes with windows and you
could go in and you could open up a
window and it would have something
written inside and then you that window
would then tell you to go and you could
cross-reference that to some other
window so the idea was that somebody
could go in and sort of extract
information out of this thing and he
claimed that anybody who walked inside
would come out and be as a smart a
Cicero or something and he had a whole
kind of sales pitch and he actually
raised money from the King kind of like
venture capital to build this thing and
and then he went bankrupt and all the
money to spirit
familiar story if you for some of us but
maybe it's just an interesting sort of
side note I'm just skip ahead a little
bit so I know we want to leave some time
for questions so I wanted to talk a
little bit closer to the present day and
talk a little bit about the effects of
industrialization on information system
so again I'm trying to that so that
we've seen in a few different periods of
history where we've we've seen a you
know changing environmental conditions
have given rise to some kind of new
technology that has then changed the way
that people exchange information with
each other and as a result we've also
seen sort of social change sort of tied
to that phenomena well that all started
to happen again about the beginning of
the 19th century and this was during the
industrial revolution
we saw a period of a real explosion of
published information and even though
the printing press was invented in the
you know in the 15th century skipped
over that that little development um the
the real boom in printing was really
didn't happen until the 19th century
this is not particularly well understand
there was of course a boom in printing
after the printing press but it was
still for the couple of hundred years
that followed it's still a relatively
tiny subset of people really had and had
any number of books there were a few
popular books like the devotional books
that a few people had but by and large
it really wasn't until the Industrial
Revolution that reading and the
production of books became a really
common thing so and so there were a
couple of trends at work there one was
that you had this Industrial Technology
and made it much cheaper to produce
books and to produce them in mass
quantities and at the same time as a
result of industrialization you saw a
growing urban popular a growing urban
population that was increasingly
literate and so there was a growing
demand and
growing potential supply of books and so
it was really in the 19th century that
there was this huge proliferation of
text and you know popular novels you
know emerged during this period and you
know dictionaries and encyclopedias and
they were seeing all this incredible you
know incredible bursts of publishing
activity and it was also during this
time that the first sort of modern
libraries emerged and it was sort of in
response to this this proliferation of
books that you started to see really the
first great kind of national libraries
like the British Library the Library of
Congress you know and eventually you
start to see public libraries take shape
before that before the Industrial
Revolution libraries were almost all
private there were a few sort of private
subscription libraries there were some
university libraries of course but
typically even the big university
libraries they didn't really need a
catalogue particularly because they
weren't much bigger than a room and they
would often have somebody who was called
a professor of books whose job it was to
basically know everything that was in
the kept in the collection so if you
needed a book you need to know what to
read or you're researching a topic you
talked to the professor of books and
they would basically steer you in the
right direction well in the 19th century
that just became untenable there was a
huge number of books and people needed
to figure out a way to keep track of
them and so a new kind of institutional
hierarchy emerged which is what we would
think of today is that well was the
library catalog and you started to see
in about the mid 19th century the
British Library created the first sort
of what we would recognize as alive as a
modern library catalog with like subject
headings and kind of a hierarchy of
understanding about topics and subjects
and then eventually in America Melville
Dewey who I'm sure everybody's heard
I've created the Dewey Decimal System
which were still stuck with today and
and you started to see this very sort of
systematized approach to organizing
information that in a lot of ways is
really a byproduct of the Industrial
Revolution really the modern library
catalog is a very industrial artifact
and it's one that's increasingly sort of
an anachronistic I think you know in a
post-industrial world and there's been a
lot of pressure on libraries to sort of
rethink the way that they they organize
information but there were people who
were thinking about this problem quite a
while ago so there's a guy named Charles
cutter who was actually not as well
known as Melville Dewey but at the time
he was actually do he's sort of great
rival he created an alternative library
catalog system that is actually the one
the Library of Congress uses today more
or less and he wrote this essay in 1883
and he was an essay about what he
thought a library might look like in a
hundred years so it's called the Buffalo
Public Library of 1983 and he is this
notion that there might be desks with
keyboards on them with little wires
coming out of them and that people might
be able to type in a name of a book and
get a picture of the book to appear on a
screen and that it would just sort of
pop up somehow so it's pretty good so
and you know and the years that followed
a few other people started to sort of
have these kinds of ideas HG Wells wrote
a pretty well-known essay called world
brain where he also had this idea that
somehow that there could be something
like a computer that was somehow
connected something like a network and
that over time people would be able to
exchange information using these tools
and he had this idea that eventually he
saw it he actually saw it as kind of a
big encyclopedia and that eventually he
thought the whole thing would sort of
wake up and sort of somehow didn't
explain how and and that it would become
a kind of living organism in some
someway so it's doing I think this
actually kind of echoes a couple of
those quotes we've looked at at the
beginning of the presentation this
notion of sort of an emerging
intelligence coming out of the network
is something that you know it's got it's
an idea that's been around for a little
while there's another guy named tired
Chardin who is a Jesuit
who started writing some essays around
the 1940s 50s maybe and he also he was
kind of a bit of a mystic but he also
had this idea that that electronic
communications technology would
eventually give rise to new ways of
organizing information and that this
would all sort of happen in a network
and that as part of that there would be
a very revolutionary thing that would
happen and there'd be a new way of sort
of interfacing with with the world de
Chardin was actually considered very
controversial the Catholic Church
actually barred him from publishing any
of his writing they considered it
heretical because they thought that he
was actually suggesting that it would
sort of kind of divine consciousness
would somehow emerge that he considered
it very off message I guess and so but
nonetheless he actually had kind of a
cult following and there was one young
Jesuit who became a particular devotee
of his whose name was Marshall McLuhan
who actually credited the char down as
the direct inspiration for his whole
idea of the global village
so today so we could see there was this
sort of heritage of thought for you know
at least several decades after the
Industrial Revolution that something
different could come along there could
be some new way of organizing
information but no but none of these
people really built anything along you
know like that until a guy named Paul
outlay came along and I'm guessing
probably most people have probably never
heard of him
he is kind of a forgotten figure but a
pretty fascinating guy he's a French
librarian or Belgium sorry librarian who
in the early part of the 20th century
wrote some really pretty important books
which mostly have not been translated
about sort of information theory and he
had this idea that that library
librarians basically had it all wrong
that they were too fixated on the idea
of a book and that they were they were
spending all their time worrying about
how to get people to find a particular
book but his idea his insight was that
there was actually a lot of information
inside those books and that if that
information
actually be sort of liberated you could
actually create a whole different way of
of organizing that information and
people letting people find their own way
through that information so he also has
you so he wrote a lot he also drew these
great little diagrams I like doesn't
people at little Lucky Charms popping
out of their heads or something but uh
this sort of illustrates this idea
pretty well I think the idea is that you
know you have ideas and then this that
gets stored on books but if you can
actually extract that data out of the
books and file them in some way you
could actually create a whole new
interface and he had this idea and I
won't go into the details of it but he
developed a very detailed system for for
how that would work he had a very
forward-thinking kind of classification
system that he that he sketched out but
his his other insight was that the
people who were actually reading the
information or interacting with the
information could actually be part of
that process of organizing it and so his
idea was that as somebody came in and
actually pulled out a piece of
information or annotated it that would
actually become part of the record of
that piece of information and those sort
of trails through the you know through
the the documents would actually become
become a new kind of document in a way
and that that itself would take on its
shades of meaning so there's a little
I'm gonna play a little snippet of a
documentary that was made about him a
few years ago
18:34 Oakley publishes his most
important book the treatise on
documentation the book on the book this
is where we find the most visionary
pages where already the concept of the
computer emerges here the workspace is
no longer cluttered with any books in
their place the screen and a telephone
within reach
over there in an immense edifice are all
the books and information from there the
page to be read in order to know the
answer to the question asked by
telephone is made to appear on the
screen the screen could be divided in
half by four or even by ten if multiple
texts and documents had to be consulted
simultaneously that would be loudspeaker
if the image had to be complemented by
oral data and this improvement could
continue to the point of automating the
call for on-screen data
cinema phonographs radio television
these instruments taken as substitutes
for the book will in fact become the new
book the most powerful works for the
diffusion of human thought
this will be the radiated library and a
televised book so why is nobody ever
heard of this guy
right that's right well he's Belgium
well it's I'll tell you why nobody's
heard of him he actually built this
thing he actually built this whole thing
called the mundaneum in the 1930s and it
was actually quite popular and very
successful and he had people phoning in
research requests from all over the
world and he had a staff of people that
were going through and organizing this
information and writing it down on cars
in rooms and rooms full of this all this
information and had this incredible
thing figured out and had it actually up
and running and working and then the
Nazis came and they marched in and they
tore the whole thing down
they emptied out the Monday name to make
room for an exhibit of Third Reich art
and they threw everything away and he
died a broken man and total obscurity a
few years later in the middle of the war
and was Khalif or gotten for about 30
years until a guy named a professor at
UC Berkeley actually a guy named Boyd
ray word actually I'm sorry Michael
Buckland and Boyd Ray word is in New
Zealand there are two scholars who sort
of have resurrected his reputation a
little bit and have actually been going
through and trying to that written some
articles and tried to sort of you know
resuscitated some of his work a little
bit and doing some translating they're
actually rebuild Lee they have actually
rebuilt part of the mundaneum in Belgium
it's become a bit of a tourist
attraction there but but he's still
certainly better known there than he is
here but but certainly you know he was a
pretty visionary guy and he was around
long before boniva Bush who was
typically credited as the sort of
forefather of the web and we're and
rightly so a couple things about Bush
first his first name is pronounced
boniva
I found out and he is no relation to the
current occupant of 1600 Pennsylvania
Avenue
and I'm sure probably quite a few people
know something about Bush he certainly
probably best-known
for an essay he wrote he actually wrote
it in the 30s but it was published in
1945 called as we may think and in that
essay he posited this idea of something
called MMX and it's often it's generally
credited as the the sort of there's
there's a direct lineage from this to
the worldwide web sort of conceptually
there's a tree a sort of progression of
people who took this vision and worked
with it and came up with what we have
today so the mimics just I'll talk about
it just very briefly it's the idea of it
was that it was a tool for a scholar to
basically be able to sift through a
large collection of documents that would
be stored on microfilm and then to
annotate those documents and Bush's idea
was that as they went as they did that
they were similar to Ola in this respect
that they would annotate that those
annotations would actually become part
of the sort of paper trail so to speak
and would become what take on their own
meaning over time so he had this idea
that as a result of that you know you
would see these new forms of what he
called encyclopedias emerge that would
then you know but you know take on sort
of life at their own so the key you know
the key sort of features of the Memex is
that it relied on users to make
associations between documents rather
than this is where it was different from
what lays vision out lay thought there
would also be sort of a classification
system on sort of from the top down Bush
thought that the users would do all the
work and basically they would just
create their own networks of meaning
through these through these documents he
also interesting to think about how the
mimics in some ways is actually superior
to the web all of the links would be
would work both ways so you'd be able to
see where something came from if you're
looking at something you'd see what
pointed into it and that the pathways
between documents would actually be
visible so you could actually see if you
could actually follow somebody's trail
through us through a collection of
documents so those are things they're
just fundamentally don't aren't kind of
workable and though the web is we
understand it today but it was but
they're pretty compelling ideas so I'm
gonna fast for a little bit here to for
the sake of time a couple of other folks
that I think are worth just mentioning
and I won't go into too much detail but
as kind of you know forefathers of the
web or for Eugene Garfield was the guy
who was basically responsible for the
idea of what's what we now what Google
has now calls PageRank and had this idea
that you could actually well know worth
going into details but he basically
invented the algorithm that essentially
that Google uses back in the 1950s Doug
Engelbart also hugely important figure
he built really the first working online
he's often just known as the inventor of
the mouse but he actually built the
first really working hypertext system in
the 1960s and Xerox PARC is very well
known a lot of Anglo Bart disciples sort
of were responsible for building Xerox
PARC which I think around here I
probably don't have to say too much
about but it was certainly hugely
influential and developing the vision of
the personal computer and things like a
thern ad and so forth and finally one
guy do want to just talk about for a
minute Ted Nelson who really if it
wasn't for Ted Nelson a lot of us
certainly in this city would probably be
doing something else for a living he is
probably you know directly responsible
for the existence of the web at least
Tim berners-lee who invented the web
says so says the Ted Nelson was actually
his inspiration for the web
he's a interesting character a bit he's
always been a bit of an outsider and he
in the 1970s started writing some really
visionary books about computers and he
actually invented the term hypertext and
he always had this kind of outsider
mentality a computer lib you know sort
of playing like women's lid that sort of
thing and he believed that the whole
computer industry was kind of a cabal of
corporations that were sort of driven by
you know government and big company
priorities and he had a very different
vision of what computers could be and
how they could work and how they could
really be tools for individual you know
individual use and individual sort of
creativity and he had this idea that
there could be sort of networks of
computers that would allow people to
collaborate and to
you know to create new kinds of
documents and engage engage with each
other and he you know and wrote a lot of
visionary things he spent a good part of
his career trying to actually build this
a sort of almost mythical project called
San I do that for a long list of reasons
has never quite come to fruition but
reading his work is really pretty fast I
mean the guy is is a genius he's also
about half crazy but he's is his work is
really fascinating he comes up with all
these just fascinating terms which I
don't have time to go through all these
but some of these ideas are just really
incredibly insightful I'll mention a
couple of them the notion of
transclusion it's the idea that you
could rather than just have a link
between documents you could actually
include part of a document in another
document and have it update update in
real time and actually they can be sort
of a live connection between documents
they could sort of like see through each
other in some way you know so ideas like
grand systems which are kind of big sort
of medical elections of documents that
are operating somewhat different way
from sort of lower level pieces of
information so enough time to go into
all this but he's deserves to be more
read and fortunately found out recently
they've tried to put together an
anthology of his writings and they can't
find a publisher which i think is just
kind of shocking but he you know he's
certainly his work is a little hard to
get through he's a very colorful writing
style but he's really really brilliant
there's some really worthwhile ideas I
think have been sort of left by the
wayside in the web and its current state
so speaking of the web this is what Ted
Nelson has to say about it
he doesn't doesn't think much of it but
may just be sour grapes but but I think
it is worth you know I think one of the
great sort of benefits of going back and
looking at some of these earlier systems
is that we can see that you know that
things could have turned out differently
and you know we tend to I think the web
has become such a dominant cultural
force that we tend to sort of take it
for what you know it's it's sometimes
hard to think about how things could be
different but in a way it's actually
very limited compared to the vision of
what some of these early forebears had
there are a lot of the sort of
fundamental problems
the Weber actually anticipated and even
solved by some of these earlier systems
I think there is value and actually
going and taking a look back at at some
of the systems that came before for
ideas that that you know that might help
us find a way forward so which brings us
up to where we are now this is a
screenshot of one of the first images of
the of the web on Tim berners-lee's
machine and that was actually a picture
I took his machine was on displaying the
Louvre a few years ago that was the next
machine where he actually invented the
world wide web so so we're gonna be
running out of time soon so I wanted to
just close by trying to connect the dots
a little bit I know I've covered a lot
of ground here and my book does sort of
go into a lot of different topics and
I've tried to at least find a few themes
that seem to to recur over time well the
book is really a history book and it
tries to really just go into you know
different periods in you know in the
history of information systems and look
for interesting examples or anecdotes of
you know ways that people have organized
information over the years but along the
way I have tried to look for some
patterns that might help us to frame you
know what's going on today or to
understand some of the challenges we're
dealing with today and by taking kind of
a long-term view so I want to close just
by reading actually the conclusion of
the book which I hope will maybe sort of
make some sense of this
so it goes like this
so for most of our species history human
beings have interacted in small tightly
woven communities families villages
guilds and other social groups whose
members were bound by ties of direct
kinship or close personal affiliation
only in the past few thousand years have
people allowed themselves to be governed
by institutional bodies on the scale of
evolutionary history institutions remain
a short-lived hypothesis yet for tens of
thousands of years human beings have
interacted as social animals following
unwritten norms strengthened by kinship
reinforced by the limbic responses that
strengthen our personal relationships
and transmitted through the spoken word
today we're seeing those instincts
return to the fore as people adapt new
technologies to invoke the ancient
emotional circuitry they care
through the age before symbols the
future of memory may lie not in our
heads but in our hearts so that's it
thank you
thank you you're not just a writer
you're a designer you're an information
I've never quite know what's call me
something like so I'm interested in a
little bit of the by-play between this
body material and your own design work I
assume you're a designer before you were
researcher in this area um it's hard to
say yeah in any case as you bring your
own design sensibility into looking at
all these various systems what lit up
for you because of that well I think one
thing was interesting was this whole
question of hierarchy and you know
whether that's something to be abandoned
or not and I think as a designer
especially working with things like the
web you you're always up against this
question of how much do you structure
things and how much do you try to keep
it flat and loose and and sort of let it
sort of self organize and you know what
was interesting to me was looking at
that sort of heritage of hierarchical
systems and is there you know does there
seem to be some you know I think
hierarchy hierarchies tend to get kind
of a bad reputation as being sort of the
you know the artifact of sort of
institutional hierarchies but they're
actually other kinds of hierarchies that
maybe have have some utility for us so
well how about in the other direction as
a designer you know what from all of
this do you take to the New York Times
when you're being an information
architect figuring that out well I think
what you know one thing that's coming up
a lot at the Times is this whole
question about what's the role of the
reader and or they you know the user or
and how in this world where people are
increasingly annotating things
responding to things having an
expectation of being able to sort of
talk back how does an institution like
the New York Times that is sort of that
is predicated on that you know it's it
prides itself on having a certain kind
of you know set of editorial standards
and a certain kind of credibility and
how do you sort of maintain that while
still trying to open it up a bit
you know and that's an interesting
tension that you know I think we're
constantly working with there figuring
out what's the right balance so is the
five levels deep thing one of those
things like 7 plus or minus 2 of the
number of
keep in your mind that we never design a
web site that has more than 511 idols in
story I want to be careful to make any
rules but I think it's essentially when
I I've been involved that sharing a
project where we actually tried to test
how far people can find how how long it
takes for somebody to get lost in a
website that's nice fun and we actually
it was pretty clear we were able to
actually we had a big it was a big you
know sort of [ __ ] you know website
corporate website with millions of pages
on it and it was pretty clear that after
about six levels into like the hierarchy
of the website people had no idea where
they were they could not orient
themselves but within those four six
levels people can understand know that
ones above you know so I'm below this
level and I'm above this level but
beyond that they just couldn't quite
their brains couldn't quite process it
so so there might be something there
here's a question from Laura will turn
where's Laura right here the argument
that the web has strong characteristics
of orality over literacy is compelling
with a growing prevalence of video
online like YouTube and so on do you
think it is becoming more so and as a
better medium for expression of oral
cultures that's great yeah this is a
real kind of throwback situation yeah
getting preliterate well yeah and I
think going back to sort of storytelling
as a unit of culture you know and
opening that back up or instead of
having sort of stories being filtered
through institutional
sort of gateways you know the having us
more and more of an open situation where
anybody can tell a story
who does seem I think that's a lot of
the appeal of YouTube is that that sort
of you know sort of direct personal that
the feeling of a direct personal
connection you know it's interesting
that when Walter jae-yong coined that
term we talked about a reality he
actually referred to he coined the term
secondary reality meaning it's not
exactly oral culture it's sort of
mediated or it's like oral culture it's
mediated but it's not quite the same
thing so it has characteristics of it
but we don't take that too far you know
so here's a question from Mike Phillips
where's Mike right there do you use
Hyman Minster right
businesses are structured to process
information at agencies or horizontal
oil company
are pyramids fair enough
to be researched Kevin Kelly handed me
one of his own questions what about the
idea that web technology overthrows the
need for any kind of categorization
categorization and everything is
miscellaneous you only need one category
miscellaneous well I've heard that
theory I think there is some truth to
the idea that you know the web certainly
opens up the possibilities for anybody
to potentially categorize anything in
their own way at the same time people
even just at an individual level seem to
feel an impulse to categorize things
even if it's not you know at the level
of you know the Library of Congress even
if we're just organizing like our
bookmarks or trying to keep track of
things we do seem we are putting our
email into folders for instance we seem
to have some kind of impulse to make
categories I think what's interesting
there was the question of how how
important is it to sort of solidify
those categories or to have kind of a
shared understanding of things and it
does seem like the web introduces a
challenge to the to the possibility of
having sort of stable cultural stable
container you know that works at a at a
better broader level the way like a folk
taxonomy gives a whole tribe you know a
stable understanding of things it does
seem like the web tends to fragment that
and it's hard to have those sort of
authoritative categories so it does seem
to throw that into question but but we
still seem to somehow want to categorize
things there's a question from Gareth
Spore any speculation on what libraries
look like a hundred years from today let
me you've just done for three-and-a-half
billion years of organizing information
here so you probably get a sense of a
certain directionality or thrust or are
we in a phase change now that his so it
was Chris well right that the the
singularity of information will be that
we have no idea what's on the other side
of the membrane Inc that's probably more
like it I'm a little hesitant to make
well I think it is some I think the
future is largely unpredictable but
but as far as the future of libraries
goes I actually sort of optimistic about
them at least and maybe a you know 100
year timeframe it's interesting that
over the last ten years as the Internet
has exploded and everyone's using the
web Public Library attendance is
actually skyrocketed all right
so why is that you would think that's
countering think people just be staying
home looking at their web browsers well
it actually seems like libraries play a
role beyond just sort of letting people
get information they actually seem to
fulfill some deeper need that we have to
actually share physical space and come
together to to to to read or even if
things that seem to be seemingly
solitary activities somehow people seem
to find comfort in doing them together
people come there to you know read or
even just to look at the internet
there's something about that physical
you know container that seems to fulfill
some kind of need so I think they'll be
around in some form but so libraries
will increasingly be designed as social
spaces rather than data spaces you're
starting to see that I mean I think we
got a lot of libraries you see more and
more sort of open space a lot of you
know computer terminals and you know
more playing more of a sort of community
role but but in ancient Rome libraries
also played a very similar role they
were very public libraries are actually
big in ancient Rome and people came to
them for much the same reasons they go
to libraries today they were they were
not just places to read books although
that was obviously the you know part of
the draw but they they they were also
sort of community centers as well so
impressed they've been want recently to
the REM koolhaas Library in Seattle and
it's intensely social it's beautiful as
you go I'm down the way it's gorgeous
and strange but everywhere you look
there's people doing stuff yeah the
books are all in the basement right
again basically yeah and so it's a
people show right and people go there
for the pthose right okay here's a
interestingly complex question from
looks like Chasse warmer
you mentioned your book the codification
of human knowledge systems mythologies
etc is allowing introspection thus
enabling us to better understand them
and therefore ourselves do you see a
parallel in the codification of a time
for example a 10,000 year clock thank
you how do you codify the future big
question well I think you guys are doing
that you guys got that yeah we don't
know what we're doing we think like
anyone tell us okay here's an
interesting one from Robin while you
ponder that Robin or they're waiting it
what about the difference between shared
public knowledge systems and knowledge
systems that are secret or proprietary
have these systems evolved are they in
any sense competitive with the public
systems that's a yeah that's a great
question I think there is a lot of I
mean I think right now that's becoming a
big you know growing issue as we see you
know private interests controlling
larger and larger bodies of information
I think it's also and so you we're
seeing I think for all the proliferation
of information out there and sort of the
public sphere somehow it seems kind of
paradoxical that that actually the most
valuable information it seems to be
actually becoming more privatized in a
way or you see like these you know
organize a research organizations or
Wall Street organizations I mean
information is becoming more complex
you know the instruments are becoming
more complex and the extraction of
meaning is becoming more specialized
kind of activity and it seems to be
commanding you know this the more sort
of expert specialized information is
becoming more and more expensive and
less and less available to to sort of
the public so so well certain kinds of
information are you know increasingly
freely available anyone can get a stock
quote you know the more sort of
sophisticated forms of analysis seem to
be becoming more and more privileged so
yeah that's a good question here's the
last question looks like it says at
Andrea Judith and ideas Judith
one of the main differences between oral
and lured information is that the
written word made information static
literal truth was literate the truth the
web is now taking us out of the static
form but giving us so many versions of
truth that we don't know how to sort it
what is the new definition or view of
truth in this new system well I think
it's there are some people have
suggested that we are actually at risk
of entering into a phase of cultural
amnesia because we are creating this
medium that's constantly being rewritten
or overwritten or and and may or may not
be preserved I mean you know I know
their projects I worked on on the web
you know two years ago three years ago
ten years ago that there's no trace of
them and you know there's there well
there's the Internet Archive which is
you know some of that but it's not you
know it's it's not inconceivable that
anybody could really create a stable
record of what we're creating right now
so I think there's a real sort of
unacknowledged risk that even though we
think we're creating this sort of
seemingly you know accessible you know
body of information we may just be sort
of overriding ourselves into oblivion
you know so it's so it's the idea of a
cannon basically obsolete now well or
does it have ever more value in light of
all as a ephemeral well I think there's
a point of view that actually physical
objects become more valuable you know
that's like the physical book but in
some ways becomes more you know a more
useful thing because it is static and it
does have sort of a record you know it's
interesting to look at my previous life
I went to watch I went to library school
and I remember having the opportunity to
actually pick up a Gutenberg Bible which
is you know hundreds and hundreds of
years old and that thing is still still
kicking I mean it's fine you know
no dead links in it no no dead Lakes
yeah it's work it working fine yeah and
what's interesting is that most the
books that are actually there are books
from like they're eight nine hundred
years old that are actually in great
shape it's actually the information from
about a hundred years ago to 200 years
ago that was printed on acid paper
that's corroding sort of as we speak so
you know it's hard to say what sometimes
what's what's going to be permanent but
um but yeah I think you know I would not
put a lot of stuff
and the stability of stuff that's of
electronic information I think it's an
open question how all the stuff is going
to get preserved over time we don't seem
to come up with a mechanism for that yet
so what did the librarian say on that I
mean we got Mike Keller here from
Stanford and you obviously stay
connected with the library world do they
see light at the end of the preservation
challenge it's just a hopeless morass
well I think they they gave up on trying
to archive the web a while ago because
it just doesn't seem feasible yeah but I
think they're doing what they can to
archive the print record and that
certainly there's a lot of activity
going on with the digitization of
printed text so I think that's a you
know a step in the right direction but
but there's also there's also people who
are concerned about that as you know are
we actually sort of destroying bar we
had kind of modern-day book burning in a
way we're kind of destroying these books
for the sake of ostensibly saving them I
don't know but it does seem I don't
think there's an easy answer to that
problem I think it's a fundamental
actually a fundamental technical flaw of
the web is it's actually the lack of
archiving capability so so the
hierarchical systems fail on that or the
network systems been to somehow come to
our rescue with preservation well if
there's one trend that seems to merge
over time every time a new technology
comes along there seems to be this
tension between hierarchies and networks
and every time the sort of an old higher
set of hierarchies gets ruptured or
collapses you know there's a easily a
period of chaos and network kind of
effects and that somehow new hierarchies
seem to emerge out of that so I think
and I think it's impossible to predict
but I think it's I think you know we
should keep in mind that this is a
pretty young technology and this is you
know compared to you know 20 years after
the Gutenberg press there may be you
know a handful of people who had ever
seen a book and here we are you know not
even 20 years after the invention of the
web and a billion people have used a web
browser so I think there's think there's
time though so there's light at the end
that I will say thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you